good afternoon everybody
as you all know next week the president
will reiterate the need for Congress to
act on the debt limit he will also
discuss initiating a separate process to
address the budget and Appropriations
because as we have long said we welcome
a conversation about spending priorities
while reining in wasteful spending
the president has already cut the
deficit by 1.2 1.7 trillion and his
budget cuts wasteful spending including
on big farmer and big oil and achieves a
deficit reduction of three trillion
dollars over the next 10 years
that's because the president thinks we
should cut oil gas subsidies at a time
when big oil made 200 billion dollars in
profit last year
it's because the president thinks we
should save taxpayers hundreds of
billions in prescription drug cost when
just five farmer companies made 80
billion dollars in profit last year
so the president's commitment to cutting
wasteful spending has never been in
doubt but Maga republicans in Congress
have taken the opposite approach they
want to protect wasteful spending for
Pharma big oil and other special
interests and instead put forward a
spending proposal that would hurt
veterans and devastate Federal and local
law enforcement
we've already detailed how their default
on America Act would cut 81
000 jobs from the VA reduce outpatient
visit by 30 million and increase the
disability claims backlogged by an
estimated 134 billion
sadly their bill also makes the funding
law enforcement one of the most high
profile legislative actions of their new
majority
nearly every single member of the House
Republican conference just voted to
slash the drug enforcement agency lay
off over 2 000 border patrol agents
slash cops program and Slash the FBI and
ATF budgets and they are doing all of
this just as they can continue to give
the richest Americans and the biggest
corporations a handout in doing so
they've signaled to the whole country to
the American people that they are
willing to give fentanyl pushing drug
cartels a pass hamstring the border
patrol and emaciate
the budgets of local and federal law
enforcement officers on the front lines
of fighting violent crime
the president has long said and you've
heard me say this as well and he said
this many many times don't tell me what
you value show me your budget and I'll
tell you what you value unfortunately
the Republican spending plan shows that
they value tax giveaways to the rich
more than they value law enforcement who
keep our communities safe
now today marks the 30th World Press
Freedom Day
it is not an exaggeration to say that
the Free Press is essential to our
democracy and democracies everywhere as
the president has said Evan gerskovic
and Austin Tice weigh heavy on our minds
today
and every day
their wrongful detentions are part of a
deeply troubling Trend we see around the
world
that we must stand up and call out
as you may know or as you may not know
in 2022 alone the committee to to
protect journalists estimates that 363
journalists were jailed simply for doing
their job a new record high
the the US government is doing
everything it can through our diplomacy
and foreign assistance to support
journalists keep them safe and hold
accountable the autocrats and their
enablers who continue to repress a free
and independent media
second I want to take this moment to
celebrate the return of one of your
colleagues Benjamin Hall
Ben returned to the state department
briefing room this week for the first
time since sustaining severe injuries
while while covering the war in Ukraine
we are glad to have him back
but we continue to mourn the loss of so
many other journalists who have been
killed or injured
they're as as they work to shed light on
the cofflex horror that we're seeing in
Ukraine currently
as President Biden said and I quote
today and every day we must all stand
with journalists around the world we
must all speak out against those who
wish to silence them and we must all
continue to support a free press that is
essential again to our democracy and our
democracy and democracies everywhere
in other news we will have we'll have an
announcement today that from the Biden
Harris Administration a new package of
security assistance to help Ukraine
continue to defend itself on the
battlefield and protect its people
against Russian aggression
the package which will be announced
later this afternoon by Departments of
state and defense includes more
ammunition for U.S provided High Mars
that Ukraine has been using so
effectively as well as additional
howitzers artillery and Motor rounds and
anti-armor capabilities
this is the 37th package of security
assistance for Ukraine using
presidential drawdown authorities and it
follows it follows extensive work by the
US government over the past few months
to fulfill Ukraine's request ahead of
its planned counter-offensive and ensure
they have the weapons and equipment they
need we will continue to work with our
allies and partners around the world to
support Ukraine as they defend their
democracy
finally today the world's Banks Board of
Governors elected Ajay banga as its next
president with resounding approval Ajay
has the right leadership and management
skills experience in emerging markets
and financial expertise to lead the
World Bank at a critical moment in its
history
AJ will play a key role steering the
World Bank to address Global challenges
we face like climate change at pandemics
and fragility and conflict while
ushering in the fundamental changes in
development finance that this moment
requires
President Biden and our Administration
are looking forward to working with Ajay
in this new role and bless you
thank you
has the administration determined if
there's any validity or Russia's claim
um that uh isn't attempted front strike
on the Kremlin aimed at President Putin
so we are aware of the reports but are
unable to confirm the authentic
authenticity of them at this time and so
I don't want to get into speculation
from here about what happened but we are
we are indeed aware of the reports
separately
um is does the administration see Putin
as the commander-in-chief of Russian
Cruise uh that have waged this war
against Ukraine as a lawful military
Target so look here's what I will say
um uh since the beginning of this
conflict the United States is uh
certainly not encouraging enabling or
enabling Ukraine to be on its borders
we've been very clear from from here
about that but again I don't want to get
into speculation from here about the
authenticity authenticity of this report
so I'm just not going to speculate from
here
up on yesterday with the announcement on
1500 troops going uh to the Border
Administration planned to take any
additional steps in the days ahead
um once the covet era restrictions
expire in a few days
do you feel ready for what may be coming
next on the border so look as you
mentioned we announced the Department of
Defense announced uh that they will have
personal Personnel troops supporting CBP
at at the border and this is has
occurred as I mentioned here at the at
the podium for more for almost two
decades it is going to be in the role of
Performing administrative tasks data
data entry and also warehouse warehouse
report it will allow CBP to actually be
able to perform their duties which is
critical to their law enforcement duties
if you will they will not be engaging
with the migrant so just want to be
clear about that we have been this
Administration for the past several
months and you've heard from the
Department of Homeland Security a couple
of times in the past several months
you've heard from the Department of
State as well when they did their their
press conference last week we've been
preparing for what is to come when title
42 is lifted and we have put programs in
place and and you know we will have more
to share whether it's process centers
whether it's the troops whether it's the
parolee program we have clearly the
president is using this Administration
is using the tools that they have
available to them to deal with to deal
what will uh the next steps I should say
after title 42 lifts
um I will also add and we've been saying
this again you know Congress needs to
act they need to stop Republicans need
to stop doing political stunts and need
to come to the table and and deal with
this in a bipartisan way the president
has taken this very seriously as you all
know on the first day of this
Administration he put forth a
comprehensive immigration a plan because
he understands how critically important
this issue is
I understand that you can't confirm the
authenticity of this alleged drone
attack but regardless of that how
concerned are you as Ukrainian officials
have suggested that Russia could use
this to launch some new kind of
provocation so look I want to be super
mindful here again we've heard the
reports uh not something we want to uh
that we are able to confirm want to be
incredibly mindful here it is really too
early to tell as you ask me about the
false flag essentially but obviously
Russia has a history of doing things
like this but again I don't want to
speculate I don't want to get into
hypotheticals from here but we're just
unable to confirm at this time and on
this steps that you are taking to
prepare for the end of title 42 this
agreement was announced you know
overnight between the U.S and Mexico can
you just help us understand how many
migrants will Mexico continue to accept
under this new agreement and for how
long they had agreed to today I believe
the 30 000 a month so just a just a
couple of things for folks are aware
um uh so while Republicans continue to
push to lay off 2000 border uh Patrol
agents we are firing on all cylinders to
prepare for the return to title eight uh
on May 11th and so last week the Biden
Harris Administration announced still
sweeping measures that I mentioned
moments ago from the state and DHS to
expand legal Pathways launch Regional
process center surge Asylum officers and
judges and more and yesterday as you are
alluding to here Mary we announce
additional joint actions with Mexico
including participation in Regional
processing centers and continuation of
effective bordering enforcement measures
under title eight and so we're using all
the tools available to us I don't have a
number to share at this time but this is
something that again we're taking very
seriously as we head towards the lifting
of title eight on May 11th we are doing
everything that we can to put programs
to put processes in place to deal with
what will occur at the border again we
need Congress to act as part of this
agreement though Mexico has agreed to
continue accepting migrants from these
four countries that have been turned
away at the U.S border as part of this
agreement is the U.S providing any
funding to Mexico so not going to get
into these are diplomatic conversations
that are happening diplomatic uh
diplomatic discussion certainly not
going to get into that from here but I
can say this our two countries are
committed to working together and to
address our regional migration Challenge
and we've both taken action to address
this humanitarian situation Mexico as
you all know is a sovereign country that
makes its own decision and we welcome
their partnership in this as we have
been partners with uh uh with others uh
in in the region again just not going to
get into diplomatic conversations from
here okay
you mentioned the administration is
preparing for what is to come or what
will occur after title 42 lives can you
describe or provide some detail as to
what the White House is anticipating
when this covered era border restriction
expires I'm not gonna
look
we know um and I've said this we have
tools that are in front of us that the
president's going to use to deal with
what we are seeing at the border and
this is something that the president has
taken initiative on since the beginning
of this Administration and we want to do
this in a safe orderly and humane way
that has been kind of the Mantra of how
we see moving forward with the
immigration system and we're doing this
without help without assistance from
Congress republicans in Congress in
particular and uh and we're doing
everything that we can to be prepared
for once title 42 lives don't have any
numbers to share for you at this time I
don't have
um we don't have a kind of speculation
or hypotheticals on what will happen
once title 42 lifts we just know that we
are preparing for that for that to occur
on May 11th and we'll continue to do
that again you've heard from the
Department of Homeland Security you've
heard from the Department of State that
they've held a press conference just
last week to lay out some of the
processes and some of the tools that we
are using well
and the Administration has taken
unprecedented measures be it deporting
now certain non-mexican Nationals to
Mexico for the first time preparing to
roll out an asylum regulation how
confident is the president that this
will drive down numbers while also
facing criticism from his own allies
that he should not be taking these steps
and then also is he talking to the
Mayors who are asking for more
assistance so those are two separate
questions I'll take the first one as you
talk about uh criticism for our from our
allies the president put forward a plan
to manage the challenges that we're
seeing at the border on his first day
and uh you know again Republicans
refused they refused to come to the
table they've refused to pass the plan
to fund to fund the plan that he put
forward and so until Congress Acts were
using the tools that we have available
to us to face this challenge again a
safe orderly human way of moving forward
with what we're seeing at the border
we're expanding legal Pathways for
protection we're limiting unlawful
immigration we're increasing border
security and we're working with regional
Partners to jointly manage this
challenge as we just announced Title VII
uh with Mexico as it relates to cities I
have said this yesterday that you know
we are in regular communication with
cities Mayors and cities across the
country who are dealing with this issue
the state department and Department of
Homeland Security put out a plan to
manage Regional migration flows and
reduce unlawful migration and you know
they are also in regular touch with
border communities and will be awarding
an additional 250 290 million dollars in
the upcoming weeks to support them so
that is the assistance that we are
providing to them we are committed to
managing this challenge again in a safe
orderly and humane way that is what we
have said since the beginning of this
Administration that's what we will
continue to do okay
um just a quick question on Russia a
senior called the acquisition from
Russia a sign that the Kremlin was
planning a major new attack I know you
don't want to speculate on the uh the
authenticity of the attack uh overnight
but do you does the U.S have any signs
to believe that the Russians are
planning a new major attack so you know
just not going to not going to just get
ahead I'm not going to get ahead of I I
know about the conversation or that
reporting just don't want to be really
careful I just don't want to I'm not
able to confirm anything from here and
so just don't want to speak further on
that
just just anything on false flag
operations and you know how how they
have evolved we continue to sort of see
the administration talk about it
any any new details I mean just as I
said moment to go to your colleague look
we we know that Russia has a history of
doing this they have a history of doing
false flag it is not unusual it is
incredibly common I just don't want to
speculate at this time and a quick one
on um on the AI meeting happening
happening soccer
who White House decided to have this
meeting now uh who obviously saw the RNC
use AI in its uh in its video to respond
to the president's uh re-election uh
announcement and um so are you doing
this because you're the White House is
concerned about the use of AI in 24 or
elections going forward can you can you
give us any details on that so look uh
just to let folks know as you just
stated the vice president is Vice
President Harris and Senior
administrations official will meet with
the CEO of four American companies at
the Forefront of AI Innovation to
underscore the importance of developing
safeguards that mitigate risks and
potential harms while driving driving
responsible trustworthy and ethical
Innovation this Builds on the
considerable steps the Administration
has taken to date to promote responsible
Innovation that protects people's rights
and safety work that includes the
blueprint for an AI Bill of Rights and
the AI risk management framework work as
well there's going to be a press
conference this evening that's going to
discuss the administrative policy more
specifically on AI and also provide
additional information for all of you as
we go into tomorrow's meeting but
certainly this is something that this
Administration has been doing this is
part of the ongoing engagement now what
you're seeing tomorrow is just going to
be a conversation that the vice
president's having with CEO members but
this just Builds on what we have been
doing these past several months
sir to perhap
s look what I will say is this is
continues our engagement on this
particular matter we're going to have
this conversation the VP and Senior
administrative officials will have the
conversation with CEOs we have had a
kind of a comprehensive if you if you
will
study or look at into this just not
going to get ahead of of what what will
essentially come out of the
administration as it relates to the AI
situation okay
um by the time the president appears at
a dinner tonight at a little bit about
48 hours since he's had a public
appearance so what has he been doing in
that time he's been meeting with uh and
having internal meetings in the Oval
Office I had a meeting with him earlier
today with his senior a senior advisors
senior staff talking about the issues
that matter to the American people It's
Not Unusual this is something that he
does every day and like you said you'll
see him later this evening there'll be
press available for for the toast that
the president is going to is going to
give it's going to be as you know an
Open Press Avail at the top and you'll
get to see the president then
raises interest rate again today as it's
poised to do cost for Americans who are
borrowing on their credit cards
mortgages and student loans are going to
go up again so what does this
Administration have to say to Working
Families who have already slid into debt
over Rising inflation and are now going
to be paying more so here's what I'll
say first to the FED as you know first
and foremost the FED is an independent
is independent and we do not comment on
the or interfere in their policies the
president made that clear he wanted to
make sure that the FED has has space to
to make their decision and to make a
monetary policy so want to be very clear
about that as it relates to inflation
more broadly this is a president that
has uh when it comes to his Economic
Policy he's put lowering costs for the
Americans a top priority and we
understand and you hear this from the
president as well we understand that the
American people some people are still
feeling the squeeze and still feeling uh
kind of the pressure if you will of
where we are with our econ economy and
so when you look at the data there has
been there has been some some relief in
progress in fighting inflation we
Consumer Price Index most specifically
inflation has fallen over the last nine
months inflation is at the lowest rate
it has been in almost two years since
May 2020 inflation has fallen about 45
percent from its peak last year wages
Rose last month and are higher than they
were nine months ago accounting for
inflation as well gas prices are down
about 140 from the peak after Putin's
Invasion and grossey prices fell last
month for the first time since September
2020 again we understand that there's
more work to do the president gets that
and understands that that's why the
inflation reduction Act was so important
as we talk about energy costs lowering
that as we talk about health care costs
lowering that and he'll continue to do
the work to see what else we can do to
help the American people
following up on on this announcement of
processing with Mexico right around the
same time that that was announced
Mexico's president set a public letter
to President Biden urging usaid to stop
funding what he called the opposition I
think usaid would refer to those as
anti-corruption and pro-transparency
groups any response to that request from
Mexico I don't have a response at this
time for them from that group request
any any response on on whether or
is that the type of agreement that could
be part of that broader uh deal on
immigration or anything timing at all
because I think people would ask
Mexico main agreement to the U.S they're
asking for something on that front is
that related I'm just not going to get
into our discussions or diplomatic
conversations that we have with another
country Mexico again is a sovereign
country that makes its own decision and
we welcome uh welcome their partnership
uh in the region on this issue
thanks so much
The Washington Post that he had not had
conversations with anyone at the White
House about those intelligence leaks is
that true and if so why not so I would
have to go back to our team I don't
actually have an answer to to that
question at this time what I can say as
we have said many times is that we have
been in discussion with our allies and
partners about about the situation I
would have to just check back to see
when's the last time they had a
conversation with President zielinski I
just don't have anything to share at
this time the critical moment that the
war is in the fact that Ukraine is
poised to potentially sometimes soon
launch it's for encounter offensive and
now this incident that we started
talking about at the top of the briefing
with the Drone
How concerned is the White House that
those leaks could strain the U.S
relationship with Ukraine at this
critical look we've been very clear I
mean we just we're about to announce uh
another uh another critical security
assistance uh to to Ukraine I think that
shows our commitment and we have been
very clear that we will support uh
Ukraine as they defend their country
against Russia's Invasion and they will
and that will continue that will not
stop uh and again we're we're announcing
a security assistance I think that shows
uh how uh how much we are committed uh
to them fighting for their freedom
fighting the Ukrainian people fighting
for their democracy and so we've been
very clear in not just security
assistance and humanitarian Aid and
economic aid and that will continue from
here very quickly has anyone has the
president or anyone at the White House
been briefed at this point on the damage
assessment by the leaks I don't have
anything to uh to preview or lay out for
you at this time and then just on the
debt limit there are conversations that
have been reported about potentially
invoking the 14th Amendment which would
essentially allow the president to deal
with this debt limit crisis unilaterally
can you characterize how serious those
discussions are have they gone all the
way up to the level of the president so
look we're not going to entertain
scenarios where Congress compromises the
full uh credit the full faith and credit
of the United States
we've been very clear from here the
president has been very clear that
Congress must act this is their
constitutional duty to act and we must
avoid catastrophic threats to our
economy that needs to happen and what
this will do it will hurt the American
people costs more than 6 million jobs
and threaten Social Security threatened
Medicare and Medicaid payments and so
we're just not going to entertain
scenarios does that mean you've taken
invoking the 14th Amendment what I'm
saying is that I'm not going to
certainly uh negotiate from here or do
anything like that we're just not going
to entertain scenarios this is their
constitutional Duty and I've said this
before Republicans did this three times
they were able to do this Democrats
joined them three times in the last
Administration
people are looking at this situation and
wondering where the urgency is back in
2011 it took the president and
Congressional Republicans more than
three months
to deal why
do you think he can reach homeless
Republic
ANS we've been very clear
right we've been very clear what this
could mean for the American people
this is their constitutional Duty when
we're talking about the spending this is
something that
Republicans and Donald Trump spent
already this is we're talking about
spending that already occurred
and in the last Administration Democrats
did the right thing and came together
with Republicans and did and and dealt
with the debt ceiling three times three
times it is their constitutional Duty it
is what they are supposed they took
Congress took oath right when if you're
a congressional member you take an oath
to the American people and what you are
going to do to do the right thing
essentially and this is part of their
duty to get this done
uh and so the president has been very
clear on this we've been his
administration has been very clear on
this he's going to have a meeting with
them next a week from today with the
four leaders he's going to again
reiterate how important it is for them
to move forward and they need to put uh
you know they need to deal with this
immediately deal with the debt ceiling
immediately this is something that they
can do today if they choose
and we cannot we cannot be a deadbeat
Nation we cannot this is something that
we have been able to do
in the past 78 times since 1960
78 times since 1960. we have always paid
our debt this country has always paid
our debt so what's different now what is
different now that's something for
Congressional Republicans to answer
uh thank you Karine
um I wanted to ask the Wall Street
Journal as a report out about the Biden
Administration having renewed direct
talks with Syria to determine the fate
of Austin Tice
um and that there have been several
meetings in the Middle East with Syrian
government officials given that you
mentioned this at the top uh in terms of
press Freedom Day given that Austin
Tyson's mother was at the dinner and
President Biden recognized her I'm
hoping you can speak to this report a
little bit maybe no I appreciate I
appreciate the question
um look we cannot confirm any specific
meetings past or present as you know in
general meetings and negotiations to
secure the release of wrongfully
detained Americans that is incredibly
sensitive but I I want to be clear here
as I was at the top the president
himself called on Syria to uh to help us
bring Austin home that is something that
the president has done but want to be
really really careful and mindful and
don't want to confirm any uh specific
conversation
from the past or in the president again
these are sensitive sensitive issues
here that we need let's update at all on
that case I just don't have uh I don't
have anything uh to to share on on the
status of of the case of Austin okay uh
second um we have a report on the doj
nearing a decision on whether to charge
President Biden's son Hunter uh with tax
and gun related violations I wonder if
the White House has any comment on on
this case if it's something the
president has been following or if he
talks to Hunter
um about this case at all I have to
refer you to Department of Justice well
the question about Austin ties Debra
Tyson's mother said this week that she
believes after all these years it's time
for wrapped with Syria what's the
president's stance on that one more time
that last part yeah it's time to wrap
rochement yeah what's the president's
stance on that so look
as I mentioned uh the president himself
called on Syria uh to uh to help us
bring Austin home he has said that
before uh
look uh the president spoke to the pain
and that uh Austin's family is going
through you heard from him directly
during the during the White House
Correspondents dinner and our hearts go
out to her we cannot even imagine don't
even want to imagine what she's going
through every day but the president is
committed to bringing our Americans who
are wrongfully detained and held hostage
home and Austin certainly is one of
those Americans that we are doing
everything that we can to bring him home
and so that's what the promise has the
president has promised and that's what
his administration has continuing to
work on one more press Freedom question
uh Advocates on on Twitter today have
been talking a great deal about how the
United States is engaged in hypocrisy by
talking about how Evan gershkovich has
held in Russia on Espionage charges
because the United States has Espionage
Act charge depending against fueling
assumption he respond to that person so
what is the criticism well the criticism
is that the argument is Julian Assange
is a journalist who engaged in the
publication of government documents the
United States is accusing him of crime
and under the Espionage Act and that
therefore for the United States is is
losing the moral High Ground
High Ground the question of whether a
reporter engages in Espionage is a
function of his work so can you respond
to that look I'm not going to speak to
Julian Assange in that case from here
what I will say is and you heard
directly from the president
when today in his statement on this uh
on this anniversary but also uh during
the dinner where he talked about the
freedom of the press and how important
it is to protect uh journalists because
it is part of our democracy right it is
important to have that if we want to
have a democracy right it is part of uh
part of uh part of how we move forward
the telling the facts being able to tell
the truth and be able to report us to do
that freely and so the president's going
to continue to speak to that the
president's going to continue to work to
make sure that these Americans who are
again held hostage who are wrongfully
detained come home and that is something
that we have seen under this
Administration he was has been able to
do more than a dozen times and so you
see This president's commitment in just
this last two years we put forward
additional tools to do that to deal with
this matter and so that's what I can
speak to that's what I can speak to the
president's commitment on this I'm not
going to weigh in on comments about
Julian Assange okay uh thanks on the
debt ceiling has the president ruled out
supporting a short-term extension of the
debt selling is that you think that's
something that you might talk to
Congressional leaders what he's going to
talk to Congressional leaders about and
we've been very clear he's going to talk
to you about how it is important for
them to do their constitutional Duty as
it relates to the debt limit and the
debt ceiling uh as it relates to the
budget and Appropriations we have
conversations with Congress every year
on how to move forward with that how to
uh negotiate on that so that is a as a
conversation certainly that we are
willing to have uh but the debt ceiling
Congress must act this is something that
they need to do immediately they cannot
hold the American economy hostage I'm
not going to get into uh uh any you know
any you know you asked me about
short-term not certainly not going to
negotiate from here or talk speak to
anything uh related to that what I know
is what the president has been very
clear about which is making sure that he
speaks directly to uh to uh to
Congressional members next week on
Wednesday and let them know lay out what
is at stake and that's what you're what
that's what they're going to hear from
him they're subject some data came out
showing that eighth grade test scores in
the U.S history reach their lowest
levels on record and what can the
administration do to help kids catch up
look as you just said kids have lost so
much in the pandemic this is why when
the president walked in he made that he
made a priority uh to open schools one
of the things that was important to do
to make sure that our kids who have lost
so much were able to go back in person
school if they choose have the resources
that they needed that to really succeed
and move forward in their education and
we saw that unfortunately the pandemic
had a a unfortunate effect on our young
our young people and our kids and so
this is again something that the
president was committed to that's why he
fought so hard to get the American
Rescue plan done that's why which
allowed him to open up schools open up
small businesses to get shots and arms
so that we can deal with this pandemic
now we're in a different place with
covet and that's because of what this
president has done is there more work to
do absolutely but even before the
pandemic there was always more work to
do as it relates to education and so our
secretary of education certainly is
doing the work to do that but yes this
is something that the president is
concerned about that the secretary of
education is concerned about and we're
going to continue to do the work to make
sure our kids have the resources that
they need and it goes back to what House
Republicans put forward with 22 percent
cut on Veterans 22 percent cut on
education that's not how we move forward
that's only hurts our kids
get April and I'll come back bring two
questions on deadlines May 11th the
deadline to release some let go of the
emergency declaration for covet with
that said what happens to those who are
uninsured when it comes to vaccines and
the fear that since the
the Declaration is lifted that people
will not look at getting vaccines
thinking that covet is over those two
questions on that there's a fear we
understand that that could happen once
because every time like when you say
they're no more you don't have to
necessarily wear masks people thought it
was over
um and when the president said that
we're not in the pandemic people thought
it was over and now with the Declaration
being lifted
so ahead of of May 11th the
administration will be sharing relevant
additional information to prepare
federal government and also the American
people as we move out of the emergency
phase of the pandemic I was asked here
yesterday
um
about the uh the covid uh coveted
response office and what was going to
happen uh and uh so one thing I do want
to to share with folks in the Omnibus
budget package of fiscal year 2020 2023
uh Congress called for the establishment
of this office this is the office of
pandemic preparedness and response uh in
the white house and we are working to
stand this team up to stand up this team
so we will have that team uh available
uh but again we're going to have more
information I want to be very mindful
um uh I I hear your questions about
vaccines I want the American people to
know that the coveted vaccines remain
highly effective to reduce the risk of
serious illness hospitalizations and
death uh you know this announcement that
we're making is is possible because of
the historic progress that we have made
over the last two years to fight coven
and ensure that people have the
information and tools they need to keep
themselves and their communities Safe
And So It remains highly
effective it is important for them
American people to know that we are in a
different phase of covet as I just
mentioned and that's why we're able to
do the announcements that we're we're
going to see once May 11th were they're
going to lift essentially once May 11th
arrive
sure and and that was part of my first
answer we'll have more information to
share
you guys we will have more information
to share as we get closer to May 11.
question
um
looking back at the prior Administration
and how deadlines
um were met and neither side blink
particularly Republicans is there a fear
a real fear
that come June
this will not be settled
and there could be indeed
um defaults
payments not made to
various persons of this Nations to
contractors those who are on benefits
Etc is there a real fear of that as
Republicans in the past and past
administration didn't blink on issues of
finances when it came to deadlines well
that's kind of taking your last Point
first that's kind of what I was saying
in the last Administration Democrats
puts put aside their politics and they
came together with Republicans to make
sure that we dealt with the debt ceiling
that is something that Democrats did we
have never never defaulted
in our history we've never done that
we've always paid our debt you heard the
president say this just two days ago we
are not a deadbeat Nation so the
president's going to be very clear we're
not going to let House Republicans take
our entire economy and millions of
Americans jobs hostage we're not going
to allow that that's what you're going
to see from this President on May 9th
and we're going to be very clear about
this this is their constitutional duty
of course we have concerns of course we
do that's why we've been saying this
over and over again that Congress must
act we're talking about more than six
million jobs we're talking about
Medicare Medicare Social Security we're
talking about our seniors our veterans
and this should not be allowed and so
the president's going to make that very
clear to report to uh to the leadership
specifically speaker McCarthy when he's
here a week from today
I think a couple questions
um on the debt ceiling uh assuming
obviously that speaker McCarthy doesn't
go into the meeting next week and say
you know congratulations you've got to
clean debt ceiling increase what
realistically is the president expecting
to get out of that meeting in terms of
commitment agreements anything on the
debt cylinder budget he's going to make
it clear to speaker McCarthy what's at
stake he's going to make that very clear
they're going to have a conversation
they had one earlier this year and this
is a continuation of that conversation
to make very clear that Congress must
act
nothing Concrete in terms of I'm just
I'm not going to get into hypotheticals
or ahead of what what is going to come
out of the meeting what I can tell you
is what the president is looking to do
and what the president wants to talk
about is how important it is for
Congress to act how important it is for
House Republicans to to immediately deal
with the debt ceiling and that is the
conversation that that we have already
said is going to occur it's going to
happen certainly not going to get ahead
of of what is going to be discussed or
what's going to not discussed but what's
going to come out of this discussion and
secondly on the end of the public health
emergency is the president playing to
mark that in any way publicly and in his
mind does this effectively kind of mean
the end of the covet epidemic at least
in the U.S so we've said we're in a
different phase of this pandemic the
reason why we're able to to to do uh the
public health emergency and make the
announcement that we have made on the
Covey vaccine is because of the work
that this Administration has done period
because of of this leadership that the
president has has been able to do period
and that's because again the American
Rescue plan what he was able to do on
day one how he wanted to make sure that
Americans uh were vaccinated how he
wanted to make sure that our schools
were open small businesses were open
that the economy got back on its feet
and you see that with the economy
currently 12.6 million jobs created
that's important and it's and we're
going to continue that work you see that
with his environmental excuse me his
economic policies that he's put forward
his economic legislation that have been
passed with the help of Democrats in
Congress and so uh look we're in a
different phase
and and it's because of the work that
this president has done if we expect the
president to mark that everyone yes I
didn't answer that question don't have
anything to uh to lay out for you on any
type of event to mark that
um the FED just raised interest rates
again and you mentioned that inflation
has come down but it's still stuck at
five percent is the is the president
frustrated that inflation isn't coming
down more quickly
the president
not gonna comment on the on the fed and
it's policy decision they're independent
we're going to respect that give them
the space to make their monetary uh
policy decisions as they have done under
this Administration for the last two
years so I want to be very clear on that
the president is working every day uh to
to make sure that we do what we can and
and meet the American people where they
are on lowering cost that's why he took
some historic actions that's what we
were able to do the inflation reduction
act that's why we were able to lower gas
prices as uh Russia as uh President
Putin started this aggression on Ukraine
and this war and so we'll continue to do
that let's not forget what the lowering
costs for families what we've done we've
lowered prescription drug costs capping
insulin at 35 a month for seniors
allowing Medicare to negotiate lower
power helping lower energy bills that's
important that's what we have been able
to do as an Administration where maggot
Republicans they are doing the opposite
they're getting programs at lower cost
lowering costs take take our economy
hostage with the default that's what
they're threatening bring back fail
trickle-down economy that's not what the
president believes he believes on
building an economy from the bottom up
and middle out so we're doing the work
uh that that we believe needs to be done
we always understand there's more work
to be done and uh and and again I've
laid this out earlier inflation has
fallen over the last nine months that's
important we saw that in the CPI data
and uh and so do we we need to do more
work on this yes but inflation also has
fallen 45 from its peak last year and
that is because of the work that this
president has done because of his
Economic Policy plan what's important to
the White House at this point to keep
bringing down inflation or to prevent
more economic slowdown
I don't think it's one or the other uh I
think the president understands that
when he's president he has multiple
things that he needs to uh he's he needs
to deal with we have said uh that we see
the economy moving towards a transition
of more stable and steady growth we see
that uh in in the data we see that in
our jobs data that we saw just last just
uh just last month and so we're seeing
that we believe that that's where we're
headed but of course inflation is a one
of the most important things that
Americans care about is what what we're
doing to lower cost and so that's one of
the number one things that you see when
it comes to the president's economic
plan is making sure he's doing
everything that his administration can
to do just that
um before we came out here there was a
shooting in Atlanta police are searching
for a suspect uh there's one dead thing
that we scored now has the president
been briefed on this what can you tell
us so I can confirm that the president
and the vice president is aware of
what's uh what occurred
um uh the Atlanta shooting so I can
certainly confirm that
uh and to go back to the nation's report
card that you talked about just to
underline some of the data 13 of
students it found in eighth grade
performed at or above the proficient
level in U.S history in civics
government it was only 22 beyond the
pandemic closures that you talked about
in your answer is how concerned is the
White House about what Young Americans
are learning about history and
government right now uh well look we've
spoken to that uh before uh how it is
important uh for look is important for
our kids to learn about the history of
this country
uh the the the uh the amazing good part
of it and also the part that we have to
learn from we've said that before uh so
yes it is it is a concern to us
but again we are uh
our kids education is a priority for
this President as you know you heard him
say because you know Dr Biden as well is
a teacher and educator so that is uh
that is uh so you have two two people in
the administration that truly care about
our kids and their education and how
they're moving forward and you have a
secretary of education that's very much
focused on this and has made our kids a
priority uh in the past two years and
we'll continue to do that
scheduling questions um president said
in Laura said he was going to visit East
Palestine Ohio at some point to review
the recovery
from the brain derailment any update on
that and tomorrow is the president
holding any events for a National Day of
Prayer
and events for National Day of Prayer I
don't have a in front of me what the
president's going to be doing tomorrow
trying to think what tomorrow is we'll
certainly share that in the next couple
of hours what his day will look like
tomorrow so you all will have that as
you normally do so that is uh the normal
here so as the president said he will go
to East Palestine I don't have any
travel plans at this time to announce
from here just to remind all everyone
the president at his Direction Federal
teams have been on the ground in East
Palestine to support response efforts
and hold North North Southern
accountable they went door to door to
check on families they were monitoring
the air they they're investigating the
cause of derailment and the Department
of Justice is suing Norfolk Southern to
seek damages and hold them accountable
and that has been our commitment to the
community of East Palestine and will
continue to be and when we have uh
travel to sheriff certainly we'll do
that
next Green um back in March the
president said after the svb collapsed
that the banking system is safe he made
similar comments after the latest Bank
failed earlier this week so I'm
wondering why the American people should
trust those reassurances if it's
happening repeatedly now so due to our
actions because of what the president
has done because of the of the direction
of the president Americans can't be
confident that the deposits are safe and
sound and banks have the access to
resources to meet a depositor's demand
in fact treasury has seen deposit flows
stabilize in Regional Banks the banking
system is more resilient than it was in
2008 when we saw the financial crisis
and thanks to the tough requirements the
Obama bite Administration put in place
Bank have more Capital depositors have
more protection regulars have the tools
and so we've taken decisive and forceful
actions to restore the confidence to
protect depositors to keep Financial
system them safe and not protect
investors but to not risk taxpayers
dollars and that is what you've seen
from us from the last couple of weeks so
given that how seriously is the White
House considering warnings that there
could be other problems ahead in the
bank but what I can tell you is that the
FDIC is going to continue to monitor the
situation and that's what I I can I can
share we have taken forceful actions
decisive actions to make sure that
taxpayer dollars are protected to make
sure that we give confidence to the
American people and that is something
that you're going to continue to see the
president has asked Congress to take
action so we've been very clear and he
has called on Regulators to reverse a
series of steps taken during during the
prior Administration and that is
something that just didn't start that
the the asking Regulators to take action
that didn't start just a couple weeks
ago that started through or very early
in his administration and then uh
thirdly and lastly
um New York became the first state to
ban natural gas in new buildings
essentially starting in 2026. does the
president support these types of
policies at the state level so this is
the first I'm hearing about that so I
don't have any comment for you on that
at this time
okay thank you Corrine uh is there
there's been so much anticipation ahead
of next week's meeting on the on the
depth on debt ceiling uh the president
always says he likes to negotiate face
to face would he commit to having as
many meetings as it takes because what
we're doing is talking about this one
day which is a week away I don't have
any further we just got to get through
the first meeting first which is a week
from today uh before we add on any other
meetings that is going to be up to the
president to decide and what I can say
he's going to make it very clear uh to
speaker McCarthy that they need to act
they must act it is their constitutional
duty to deal with the debt limit
and uh here a week ago he announced his
re-election campaign this is not a hard
shot question
um so you know that that was that was a
week ago uh I'm just wondering he's got
obvious he's got his main job which is
being president um he's going to be you
know normal doing his other job which is
trying to become president again
um will he will he travel a lot more
than he's been doing in the past would
you think we don't have anything to
share at this time on his travel whether
political or official just not going to
show anything to share at this time okay
yeah another question on the Atlanta
shooting I wonder if the president is
frustrated by the frequency at which
we're continuing to see these mass
shootings despite that gun safety law
that was passed last year and does he
think the full effect of that law has
really started to show so a couple of
things I as we as it was mentioned we
were coming out here the news was
breaking so I want to be very clear
we're monitoring the situation situation
we'll have more information it's an
ongoing a very fluid situation as far as
I understand I don't know what else has
occurred since we've been out here I
want to tell the public that we urged
him to heed guidance from officials and
keep themselves safe please keep
yourself safe as this as the situation
continues so just want to be very clear
about this and don't want to speak to
this directly because we just don't know
uh exactly what is uh what is I know
there's a shooting but we don't have all
of the information it's very fluid
um so look is the president frustrated
about what we're seeing in our
communities and our schools and our
churches and this epidemic that we've
seen this gun violence epidemic and this
is a yes of course he's frustrated this
is a president that has taken historic
actions the first two years executive
actions signed as you mentioned to me uh
a a piece of legislation that was
bipartisan and it was the first
legislation that we had seen in 30 years
to deal with this issue but we know that
more needs to be done we know that
Congress needs to take more steps to
deal with the violence that we're seeing
again in our communities our schools our
churches which just should not be
should not be American people should be
able to feel
forgoted to to uh to go to into a
grocery store to go to church our kids
should feel free and feel safe and our
teachers administrators should feel safe
to go into a school and right now we're
seeing weapons of war on our streets we
should not be which should not be and so
we've been very clear about Congress
needing to act and I think we're all
frustrated I think there's parents out
there who are frustrated there are
Americans out there who are frustrated
and who wants to see an assault weapons
ban which reduce mass shootings when
when something that the president LED on
in 1994 we want to see Common Sense gun
law reform whether it's requiring
background checks on all gun sales
requiring safe storage of guns
eliminating immunity for gun
manufacturers who knowingly put weapons
of war again on our streets these are
the things that we want to see Congress
act on and so we're going to continue to
call on them to do so
okay
um Julie sue the nominee for labor
secretary has yet to be confirmed by the
Senate and could face some roadblocks
ahead what is the administration's level
of commitment to sue as the nominee if
the votes aren't there so we are
committed uh to uh Julie Sue's
confirmation process she's met with
dozens of senators on both sides of the
aisle and we're working very hard every
day for every vote that is certainly
something that she's doing certainly
something that we're doing on her behalf
we're feeling confident about her
process and looking forward to the floor
consideration in the near future I would
just remind you all as I've said before
from here when she was confirmed for
deputy secretary she got she got all
Democrats in the Senate and so we're
going to continue as I said she's met
with both senators from both sides of
the aisle and we certainly feel are
feeling confident in this process
um
oh okay let me call some more people in
the back uh good sir thank you Curry
um question on the press for today so on
the anniversary at the same time we see
China just announced we're doing its uh
counter Espionage law which worries a
lot of journalists also support Masters
currently we have at least 127
journalists detains in China including
three foreign reporters in Canada
entrepreneurs charge what is an
Administration take on China suppressing
even more freedom of speech is the Press
Freedom part of the conversation between
us and China so look what I can say and
is that we are doing everything that we
can through our diplomacy and foreign
assistance to support journalists to
help them keep them safe hold hold
accountable the autocrats and their
enablers who continue to repress a free
Independent Media and that's what you
can can count on from this
Administration that's what the president
made very clear in his statement today
but also his remarks that you heard
directly from the president just this
past Saturday and that's why we're
lifting up this day this 30th uh 30th
World Press Freedom Day uh and so uh
we're committed we have put fourth tools
to deal with ways uh to continue to make
sure that we're protecting a wrongfully
detained and Americans who are held
hostage you heard us announce just some
tools just last week and we'll continue
to do everything that we can again I
said this earlier this is an
Administration that has brought home
more than a dozen uh wrongfully detained
and Americans held hostage in his first
two uh two years of this Administration
so that shows our commitment and will
continue to work towards that
okay
um go ahead Naomi thank you
um so back to interest rates the FED
also signaled that it could be the last
increase after more than a year of
heights should we read this as
potentially there being a stronger
likelihood of a recession I'm not going
to get into uh the fed's policies
monetary policies from here they are an
independent agency we are giving them
the space to make decision on monetary
policies we are not going to interfere
in their policies so not just I'm not
going to get into a hypothetical from
here
sorry in the background screen when it
comes to immigration obviously the
administration wants uh immigration
reform but why hasn't the president
brought in Congressional leaders and
tried to show leadership and come up
with some kind of compromise that could
pass we've shown leadership we showed
leadership on day one on day one
by putting forth a piece of legislation
to deal with Comprehensive immigration
reform that's the leadership that this
President showed on day one to show his
commitment to uh to making sure we have
a safe and orderly and Humane a way to
deal with immigration to fix a to fix a
system that is certainly broken and has
been broken for some time so that is the
president's leadership we're using the
tools that we have because Congress
doesn't want to help we've we've uh
called Congress and we've spoken to
Congress many times are certainly our
office of ledge Affairs and other
departments here in the White House
certainly have had those conversations
over the last two years and the
president has been very vocal but we
have to have to use the tools that we
have in front of us to deal with this
issue and and we've continued to call on
Congress to act the president has
members of his administration has I have
numerous times and now we are going to
do what we can from here to make sure we
do this in a way that's safe in a way
that's orderly and the way that's humane